one other thing to bear in mind is that
when you're when you're when you're
fundraising you're not competing against
your competitors
you're competing against everybody else
who's fundraising at a similar stage
and so your ability to think about
running a process a tight process which
i'm going to talk about at the end of
this presentation and
iterating on your deck continuously is
going to have a profound impact on how
polished you look
when you're talking to an investor most
founders
will iterate on their deck and their
narrative as
they are meeting investors
i'm a big proponent of not meeting with
investors when they ask to sit down with
you
like at all someone asks you to invest
if they can take a meeting do not meet
with them
say no and instead say right now we're
not capital constrained
and we'll let you know if if we open a
process or when we open a process
the reason you want to do that is
because you want to meet with just
founders for the first month
before you sit down with investors so
leading with product is really important
this is how our sensors work this is
like what our sensors see and it
demonstrates sort of the complexity of
the problem that we have to solve and
the simplicity of our solution
by showing weird human behavior the
reason these things are helpful is that
they really ground
someone who's looking to write a check
and who the hell you are and
what the hell you do instead of in
abstract concepts about
tam you've noticed i've not talked about
talked about tam i've only talked about
product i've only talked about people
and that's because these are things that
we think have like a material
bearing on who we are and and what the
value is to a customer
typically show a bit more about machine
learning by the way i have some of my
own advice on
what i might improve here if you have
great numbers lead with your numbers
there's another really good piece of
advice um i'd bury the numbers and in
fact i think this might be a data deck
this was uh this became like our fourth
slide i think
the macro was covid had hit and it was
accelerating the urgency and compressing
sales cycles and we had grown
really materially month over month and
or a quarter of a quarter
and it was because the pandemic had
increased the urgency by which people
had cared about how people were using
space
now the one thing to bear in mind here
is that while the pandemic was having
that impact we were already on track
to grow by hundreds of percentage points
quarter of a quarter the thing that was
really important is that it it went
further than that and our sales were not
interrupted
by the pandemic and so this is as much
about showing that you have sort of
contextual awareness of like the op
the market that you're in and what's
going on and are doing objection
handling ahead of when questions come up
again if you have good data lead with
the data our tcv to cac
is um is is real it was really good and
substantially larger than
what sort of industry standard or best
practices are and so we just kind of
show that here's what our payback period
is
here's when our customers pay uh here's
our cost to acquire relative to the
average deal size the reason this is
useful
is you're raising capital to do
something so if you don't understand
sort of like what you're going to do
with that capital
it makes it substantially harder to to
raise because you can't really justify
where you're going to spend it
the reason you invest is because you're
trying to put ideally
fuel on a fire now this uh changes
depending on the stage so
earlier stage is more about on the team
mid-stage
or or late early stage is more bet on
early product
mid-stage it's more a bet on early
traction call it mid to late stage
before growth
it's on repeatable economics so like you
can actually do this
and that's where these numbers start to
become really relevant is
how can you take my dollars and triple
or quadruple
again if you have good numbers lead with
numbers like pipeline growth was really
material and
it's really important that the pandemic
we raised 51 million
series c in the middle of a pandemic our
round was open for about nine days
that's the sound bite and that's what
everyone goes you know that's really
cool like
that's a lot of money and and it's over
a very short period of time
the the reality is that preceding that
nine days was 60 days of prep
it was dozens and dozens and dozens of
meetings with founders to get feedback
on
this deck which is now a year and change
old it was
repeatedly it was hundreds of slides
that got deleted
a really good piece of advice i once got
was you should love every slide in your
deck
and i mean and by love a good way to
think about this is that if you go to if
i go to the next slide
am i like oh yeah i forgot to tell you
you know we we grew at a certain
rate you know year over year or oh i
forgot to tell you that arr is
also growing not just tcv oh man i
forgot to show you this like
really amazing net dollar retention
number that we have now we're a little
bit we're a later stage company you
don't need to have all of these metrics
early stage you're looking at call it 11
to 12 slots
you should love every single one of them
and if you don't
delete it you know you could put it in
appendix if you'd like you can throw it
in like a
you know sort of toss it in an area an
archive area if you'd like but
my general recommendation is that like
at the end of
a process you should truly love your
deck and you should have pitched it so
many times
that it's fun to tell the story i also
want to
point out a couple things so this is an
example of a barbell strategy so a good
way to think about your deck design you
want
very high dense uh slides like this one
where you're not going to read
everything it's just not possible to
read everything
high density slides and then you want
very sparse slides and i'll give you an
example of that
like this is an example of of a very
sparse slide now the reason
you want this barbell strategy and
nothing in between no bullets like very
few bullets
is because you never want to read your
slide in a pitch instead
you want them to be prompts so this
accumulating advantage accumulating
advantage is a is a
is actually a term that keith raboy uses
quite a bit
it is the i believe the technical term
for a network effect the more common
term is network effect
but there's a variety of uh terminology
like in our case we have bidirectional
network effects where like one thing
affects it positively and the other
thing affects it affects it
positively and talking about it as an
accumulating advantage was something
that
we learned in prep so back in 2017
i was preparing for a founder's fund
meeting and i was doing a bunch of
research on
uh founder's fund and i came across he
wasn't at founder son at the time i came
across a keith for boy
interview where he talked about network
effects and the definition of an
accumulating advantage
and i i because he was at paypal i sort
of assumed that the language or the
lingua franca or whatever the term is
sort of the native language would sort
of carry over
and um he talked about like accumulate
what are your accumulating advantages
and so that became the name of the slide
because i was on youtube
just sort of listening to a podcast that
who knows maybe it was on this week in
startups with keith or boy talking about
what a network effect actually is and
why it's important
the reason that's useful is you're
essentially like so youtube is the best
podcasting service in the world just pay
for the youtube premium system
and what you can do is um just listen to
the audio instead of watch the video
with like your screen off which you
can't do with the free version of
youtube and so it becomes this huge list
of essentially audio only files that you
can listen to and
before you go into a meeting with an
investor and i'm going to talk about
sort of the process in a second
i strongly encourage you to spend the
couple days prior or the week prior just
going on youtube and searching their
name listen to everything they've done
and what it will do is it will give you
language to explain
what you were already going to explain
that they're familiar with
and that has a profound impact on how
it's received so founders fund
led around i don't think it's
necessarily because of this slide but
because we were able to sort of
talk in in in holistic terms about
things like you know we believe that we
believe in that we are building
sort of working in a small market
meaning a market that is growing really
rapidly but not one that is owned by an
incumbent the reason that's valuable
when you're talking to founders fund is
because founders fund believes in small
markets and drawing concentric circles
around
ownership of a small market such that
you can become a more dominant force
long term you know the dji dji owns 71
of the drone market even though it feels
like there's lots of drone companies
how do they do that so anyway use the
language of the investors that you're
speaking with let me just back up a
little bit
then we get to market and again this is
barbell strategy as a dense slide
um i really call out two things which is
i don't i don't know how
we count people above points of entry
and in open areas
and i don't know how many doors there
are in the world but there are a lot
and instead of trying to build a total
addressable market
by looking up some gartner report i
strongly encourage marc andreessen has
this great comment which is like count
your customers noses
so count noses it means go find your
customers your whatever customer segment
then go find the look-alikes of those
customers and count them that's your tam
and that's a much better way of building
a tam than going and saying well the iot
industry is going to grow by 23
according to you know whatever [ __ ]
report you find instead like
just do the work of counting how big
that is now we struggle
with counting the number of points of
entry in the world or the amount of
square feet in the world
i know that real estate is 280 trillion
it's a 280 trillion
asset class but the point is that um
physical space is completely unmeasured
so what i typically say here is
the crazy thing is that for thousands of
years we've been building buildings
without knowing how they get used
the state of the art today is an
architecture grad student with a
clipboard or an ipad
wandering around physical space for five
days a quarter
and noting down that room is in use
that desk has not been touched or that
bank of desks has not been touched in a
in the last few days that's how we've
been building buildings
and you know what would happen if new
york city all of a sudden knew how it
was used
would it design itself differently and
we think that the answer is objectively
yes
so the question isn't a technology
problem the technology is a very
important part of the problem the real
problem is a distribution problem
how do you get an intelligent device
into every relevant room in the world
and whoever solves that problem earns
the right to remake it
earns the right to assist in its editing
and so the
the tam is the surface of the earth it's
all built physical structures
now that that sounds stupid that sounds
like a
silicon valleyism you know i live in san
francisco but like
it's very easy to get wrapped up in the
concept of like world-changing stuff
if you believe it however and if you are
if you are really
enthusiastic about why and the logic is
sound
it is impossible to argue with ambition
and so i would encourage you to be
ambitious
but be genuine in it in this case these
are the numbers
there's a trillion dollars of space in
offices alone
that people have bought used least
otherwise occupied
and are not using at all like it's the
desk that doesn't have anybody in it
it's the conference room that doesn't
have anybody in it
and the reason that's useful is it
clearly articulates it's a very big
problem
and it's a very large potential market
even if it's still nascent
i strongly encourage you to talk about
competition not as competition but as
competing technologies or competing
products
the reality is that you are competing
with more than your competitors you're
competing with doing nothing you're
competing with
really good marketing you're competing
with incumbents that say they do
something but don't
saying that you don't compete is a is a
non-answer saying that you compete
and saying or that there are competing
products and values and
intents is a much more reasonable
position to take
strongly encourage a logo slide if you
have great logos
you know don't make them like all over
the place give them a little bit of
order
use cases make sure you make it really
clear i know i said no bullets but like
really you don't want to be reading
bullets so keep the bullets to a minimum
in this case
i don't talk about each of these but i
do talk about the use cases and i also
talk about how the difference in the
macro pre-code and postcode you have to
remember this is
literally like march april may of last
year
so covid and the pandemic was a big part
of
essentially all fundraising today it's
maybe a little bit less so but how is
that affecting use cases and where
people spend
why they're spending their dollars
strongly encourage big
imagery if you have it full full imagery
again this is sort of barbell strategy
the the point that i make here is that
you know our primary value is in the
software that we build it's not in the
physical devices
talk about actual growth from an actual
customer you know customer stories speak
volumes
so this was had to do with the growth of
154 floors 67 buildings nationwide
deployment across millions of square
feet of space and then sort of a
concluding statement
i'm reasonably sure that there's not a
future in which humans continue to build
buildings
or use buildings but don't know how
they're used in this case the pandemic
has just accelerated the timeline but
the point is that there's this great
quote and i i believe it's from
the founder of um big screen vr
i i think he essentially said um tweeted
once that uh
your job as a founder is to not die for
long enough
for the market to notice you and i
really love that because it's not
saying it it makes clear that the point
that time is such a huge
is so important to whether or not you
succeed or fail
that not dying is just as important as
building a great product sometimes